"El nuevo coloso"
de Emma Lazarus.
No como el gigante plateado
de fama griega,
con extremidades conquistadoras
extendiéndose de tierra a tierra;
Aquí, en nuestras puertas en el atardecer
bañadas por el mar, estará de pie
una poderosa mujer
con una antorcha, cuya llama es
la luz de los prisioneros y su nombre es
Madre de los exiliados.
Su mano como faro
brilla en bienvenida al mundo entero.
Sus ojos dóciles comandan
la bahía ventosa
enmarcada por ciudades gemelas.
"Tierras de antaño quédense con
sus historias pomposas!" Exclama ella
con labios silenciosos.
"¡Dadme tus cansados, tus pobres,
tus masas amontonadas gimiendo
por respirar libres,
Los despreciados de
tus congestionadas costas.
Enviadme a estos, los desposeídos,
basura de la tempestad.
¡Levanto mi lámpara
al lado de la puerta dorada!"